hey guys Pete here this is gonna be part
two of are the gods real in a game of
Thrones and if you haven't seen part one
I'll put a link right here at the top
you should watch that first of course at
the end of that one I'll put a link to
this one so you can watch them in order
no real spoilers here this is just
theory based on stuff we know from the
books but if you haven't watched Game of
Thrones through season six you probably
want to finish that up before you watch
these videos so in part one we talked
about reward the Lord of Light who seems
to be the most credible of all the
supernatural deities that we know from
the show we looked at many of the
different things that Melisandre has
done in order to figure out if they are
related to magic and is that magic
unrelated to a supernatural deity like
the Lord of Light my conclusion is that
the magic is real but the religions are
created as a way to kind of explain this
mysterious force of nature that is magic
so the big stumbling block in the theory
of everything just being magic is these
visions and flames and I said that I'd
go over some of the theories related to
what that might be if the Lord of Light
isn't actually communicating with
Melisandre and the other red priests and
priestesses if you only watch the show
you're gonna have to take my word for
some of the characters and events that
come from the books that I'm going to
use to explain this when I was actually
researching this I found a pretty good
succinct theory on reddit which I'm
going to use and I can link to that in
the description it's submitted by the
user Fagan the Conqueror
it's a couple years old and it's pretty
in line with what I've been thinking
about this for a while after reading
through the books more than once
honestly after the first read I was
pretty confused about real or because it
did seem kind of credible and that
affected other readings and I think that
this is the same place where the the
redditor is coming from so like I said
if you're not a book reader the first
thing you have to know about our glass
candles we haven't seen any glass
candles in the show and I don't believe
that we will because none of this is
going to be essential as far as telling
the end of the story as far as the show
storyline goes but basically glass
candles come from Valyria and they were
a tool that the sorcerers used to see
long distances they could also enter a
man's dreams and give them visions and
they were able to speak to one another
half a world apart seated before their
candles the power of these candles
attributed to magic as the the people in
the freehold really weren't religious
they they practice a sort of religious
tolerance for the people who live there
because they knew that was good for
controlling the population but beyond
that they're not before before Aegon
came to conquer Westeros they didn't
really line themselves up with actual
religions I mean there are gods in their
you know in their mythology and things
like that but they're just not religious
people so to look at the the glass
candles again they're basically
communication devices and there's quite
a few of them out there in the world we
know the Citadel has four of them that
are about a thousand years or more old
and it's not a hundred percent clear
exactly how they work like it you know
to communicate between two people do
people have to have a candle obviously
they can give people visions and they
can enter people's dreams with just one
and they can see things similar to what
we know about what the Greenes ears do
in the weirwood trees so we've heard
about glass candles a couple times the
first introduction is in the second book
of Clash of Kings when Zorro tells
Daenerys that the glass candles are
burning in the house of Yura thawne
nightwalker and that they haven't burned
in a hundred years later we get a much
detailed description because Samwell
actually sees one when he goes to the
Citadel when he gets there he sort of
gets taken off of his norm
path by one of my favorite characters
archmaester Marwan the mage who is not
your typical archmaester but he has a
candle Sam sees it and the candle itself
is like three foot tall with the sudden
it's very slender its ridged and twisted
and its glittering black and Sam
immediately notices that it's made out
of obsidian or dragon glass once he puts
his eyes on it we find out that these
guys have known that Sam was coming
because they saw his arrival in the
glass candle so we could guess that
maybe people knew that Daenerys was
going to Qarth
in the same way now remember the first
mention they say that they hadn't burned
in a hundred years this is almost a
hundred percent related to the birth of
the Dragons but what's confusing is that
our dragons being hatched now because
magic came back or is magic coming back
because the Dragons were hatched we
really don't know which one is the cause
and which one's the effect well we do
know though is that magic is on the rise
magical things are happening and all of
a sudden these communication devices
where you can go into a person's dreams
and control them and give them visions
have started to burn again so this is
the part where if you are believer in
real or you think this whole idea of
glass candles that's really too
far-fetched like really but it's not in
the context of the story because we've
seen a character who does exactly this
through the weirwood trees Brynden
rivers contacted Brandon's dreams and
set things in motion for a small
crippled boy to travel from his home all
the way north beyond the wall which is
pretty remarkable and would be hard to
believe if we hadn't actually seen it
happen as someone who comes from a
skeptical point of view this is
basically enough to make me think that
it's possible that the visions that
Melisandre sees in particular are
somehow being manipulated by men I get
that if you aren't from that same point
of view though that this would be a
harder stretch to make from there we
just sort of have to ask ourselves
what's the story about is it about a
classic struggle between good a good
force and an evil force or
is george RR martin trying to point out
more about you know its struggle for
power the absurdity of feudalism and so
on and so forth there's definitely a
debate there but this is not the video
for that debate so my thoughts to this
point haven't really changed I feel like
the religions in a game of Thrones that
gods are constructs but it wouldn't be
right to just look at my point of view
so in part three I'll go through one
really good explanation of real or being
real and then we'll all look at which
side we land on now before I go I do
want to point out that there are a lot
of question marks and the idea that I'm
laying out what the glass candles could
be involved in the visions isn't that it
explains everything like we really don't
know how long that Melisandre has been
having visions or the other red priests
have it's never explicitly said and we
know Maya Saunders been alive for a long
time so she could have had visions in
the past before the magic started to
kind of disappear but that gets into
some really complicated speculation and
the fact is we just don't know all we
know is that she thinks she's really
good at it and that at least during our
story she's seen some things that have
been very hard to ignore like she
definitely sees things that come from a
magical source while I find Melisandre
so interesting is is that we know for
sure that she also in her fanatical kind
of devotion to the Lord of Light uses
any trick necessary to try to convert
people to her way of thinking and what
stands out in the reading that we don't
really get in this show is that
everything she's done while she was
misled into thinking that Stannis was
azor Ahai reborn led up to her being at
the wall in the books we find out that
she is much stronger at the wall in a
dance with dragons she says that she's
even stronger there than she was in a
shy and as far as blood magic and her
shadow binding we would think that she
would be the strongest and a shy but for
some reason when she's at the wall she
starts to come into her own and realize
she doesn't need these tricks that she
uses from you know the potions and other
things and then there's resurrection and
not just her resurrecting John as we've
seen in the TV show because we haven't
got a good description of how that works
in the book yet but we also have Thoreau
Sameer who brings back beric Dondarrion
several times so that's all stuff we'll
cover in part 3 I hope you'll let me
know what you think in the comments
please like the video don't forget the
book giveaway still going on when I
reach 28 thousand subscribers I'll pick
someone who does a comment on this video
or any of the related ones and I'll send
them a copy of the 20th anniversary of a
game of Thrones by George RR martin it's
the illustrated copy and it's really
awesome there'll be a link in the
description for you to check it out and
all you have to do is be a subscriber
and leave a comment so get with it get
your chance to win tell your friends
about it and we'll see you guys tomorrow
I have some new stuff coming out and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon